pflanzen als superhelden forschungsteams
weltweit setzen große hoffnungen in das
themengebiet grüne gentechnik und die
neueste technologie in diesem bereich
das neue wunderwerk zeugt der gentechnik
vielleicht sogar der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten die gehen schere krispl
das ergebnis pflanzen die sich selbst
gegen schädlinge schützen und dem
klimawandel trotzen
ob diese technologie die menschheit vor
dem hungertod retten wird oder ob sie
ganze ökosysteme ausrotten wird jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
die gegenwehr christa ist eine riesige
revolution in der wissenschaft da sind
sich die forschungsteams weltweit einig
ähnlich wie die entdeckung der dna
damals wissenschaftlich korrekt spricht
man vom chris podcast neuen system über
das wäre ja schon ab und zu mal
berichtet haben
es steht für cluster treasury inter
spaceopal andronic repeats also frei
übersetzt so viel wie kurze abschnitte
sich wiederholender dna bakterien nutzen
krispl als eine art schutz gegen viren
denn es schneidet erbgut also dna an
einer bestimmten stelle und das sehr
präzise die bakterien nutzen diese
technik also ganz natürlich sie
schneiden ds dna aus angreifenden wären
heraus und setzten sie in die eigene dna
ein dadurch erkennen sie die viren beim
zukünftigen angriff und können sich
gegen sie wären diese technik kann aber
auch von den technikern genutzt werden
um erbgut zu verändern und es ist damit
superleicht bestimmte gene können aus
dem genom herausgeschnitten werden und
neue abschnitte an dieser schnittstelle
eingefügt werden und das tolle daran das
ganze funktioniert nicht nur bakterien
sondern auch in anderen organismen
manche bezeichnen dass christa system
deswegen auch als ein werkzeug der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten ja und diese
technologie die ist nicht nur im bereich
der grünen gentechnik der große
hoffnungsträger auch andere
herausforderungen wie die therapie von
krebs oder erbkrankheiten könnten
mithilfe dieser technologie gelöst
werden so die hoffnung vieler und einen
wirklichen haken hat sie tatsächlich auf
den ersten blick einmal nicht im
gegenteil im vergleich zu bisherigen
techniken ist sie deutlich schneller und
kostengünstiger
denn gene gezielt zu verändern das ist
nicht neu es gibt zum beispiel die
sogenannte sync finger nuklearen zf n
also künstlich hergestellte enzyme die
dna-sequenzen erkennen und gezielt
zerschneiden doch ihre herstellung ist
teuer und komplex im jahr 2012 haben
zwei molekularbiologin dass kris peeters
neuen system zum ersten mal beschrieben
der anfang der revolution und für die
beiden forscherinnen vielleicht ein
riesenschritt in richtung norbert preis
wie gesagt setzen viele
forschungsbereiche groß
zur hoffnung in die neue technologie
unter anderem auch die pflanzenforschung
bzw züchtung champignons die nicht mehr
braun werden egal wie lange sie herum
liegen seit 2016 tatsächlich in den usa
zugelassen und in den supermärkten zu
kaufen
klingt erst einmal toll doch wie genau
können wir dann feststellen wie frisch
der pilz noch ist und es gibt weitere
ideen für pflanzen die mit hilfe der gen
chirurgie ja optimiert werden können
erdnüsse die auch allergiker vertragen
oder melonen ohne lästige kerne
beispielsweise das gebiet der
pflanzenzüchtung hat eine sehr lange
tradition vielen von euch sagen
vielleicht die erbsen von gregor mendel
etwas er hat die vererbung von
eigenschaften an die nächste generation
erforscht also wie sich das erbgut
verhält wenn die eltern verschiedene
eigenschaften haben aber tatsächlich
haben auch schon die menschen in der
steinzeit darauf geachtet welche
pflanzen besonders ertragreich oder auch
besonders resistent waren und haben
diese pflanzen miteinander gekreuzt so
haben sich die wildpflanzen von damals
zu den heutigen kulturpflanzen
entwickelt die zuchtziele von heute sind
schnell zu definieren und sie
unterscheiden sich eigentlich nicht sehr
von den vergangenen immer geht es um
höhere erträge resistenzen und bands
bessere anpassungen an die gegebenen
umweltbedingungen aktuelle
forschungsprojekte tüfteln
beispielsweise an besonders
ertragreichen weizen an maispflanzen die
trotz großer trockenheit viele früchte
tragen oder auch an bananenpflanzen die
raupen verschmähen es könnte neben ware
superhelden der pflanzenwelt gezüchtet
werden mit ganz bestimmten und extremen
eigenschaften und hier kommt chris
farkas 9 ins spiel auch in der
pflanzenzüchtung überzeugt die
technologie durch drei eigenschaften
ganz besonders die schlagworte präzise
einfach und schnell in der praxis
bedeutet das dass sich die
entwicklungszeit einer neuen
pflanzensorte halbieren ließe acht bis
neun jahre dauerte das bislang dazu
kamen dann durchschnittlich noch drei
bis vier jahre dazu die die sogenannte
sorten prüfung in deutschland in
anspruch
nimmt durch chris packers 9 kann das
erbgut einer pflanze ja wie gesagt
zielgerichtet verändert werden die
gewünschte resistenz oder der höhere
ertrag werden so viel schneller erreicht
doch wie immer gibt es auch kritik und
die ist sehr stichhaltig die der große
streitpunkt in diesem kontext ist der
sogenannte naturbegriff ist solch eine
veränderung an einer pflanze natürlich
die befürworter argumentieren dass diese
veränderung auch zufällig in der natur
vorkommen würde
denn setzt punktmutationen also
tatsächlich nur die veränderung eines
einzelnen bausteine der dna kann enorme
auswirkungen auf den jeweiligen
organismus haben die christ methode sei
biologisch und keine chemie oder
strahlung kritiker dagegen halten den
prozess der herstellung für unnatürlich
also künstlich fraglich ist allerdings
ob der begriff und die argumentation der
natürlichkeit passend sind dazu das
bundesamt für naturschutz
zitat der vergleich mit der
natürlichkeit ist dabei irreführend da
eine höhere naturnähe nicht per se ein
geringes risiko darstellt zitat ende
denn natürlich ist nicht gleichzusetzen
mit gesund oder sicher die konsequenzen
die die neu gezüchteten pflanzen für das
komplette ökosystem mit sich bringen
könnten
die sind lang bislang nicht wirklich 8
zu schätzen würden die besonders stress
resistenzen pflanzen beispielsweise
andere arten verdrängen manche experten
und der experten befürchten dies welche
folgen hat die technologie auf den
menschlichen körper und unsere
gesundheit diskussionen gibt es auch zur
forschung in diesem bereich in einem
brief von 2016 fordern mehr als 100
nobelpreis träger und trägerinnen aus
verschiedenen forschungsgebieten das
grüne gentechnik in der landwirtschaft
eingesetzt wird ja es könnte den
welthunger ja vielleicht sogar
abschaffen landwirtschaft umweltschützer
sind aber skeptisch wir bleiben
natürlich dran an diesem thema wenn er
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesse
nicht den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter mit dass große insekten sterben
eine wirklich dramatische situation bei
der dringend gehandelt werden muss also
unbedingt ansehen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran